[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from GP Filipino gastropub in the East
Village where I'm joined by comedian Jo
koy hello he's a busy guy with a hugely
popular stand-up special on Netflix he's
also on and glorious pranksters in the
lol Network he's about to hit the road
for a series of sold-out shows in Hawaii
and the Philippines and as much as we
love Hawaii today we're all about the
Philippines Jo I know that you're a
Filipino food obsessive in part because
you are raised by a Filipino food
obsessive I saw that video of your mom
breaking down the spread at the Doudna
buffet yeah I loved it
this is made out of the out pig's blood
intestate and for you 15 my experience
with Filipino food it's not vast you
know for someone who knows the ropes can
you set the table it's the best blends
of everything in Asia and Spain put
together yeah I mean we got Spanish
influence we got Indian influence we've
got Asian influence
our barbecue is amazing you know there's
there's so many different varieties of
Filipino dishes it's amazing that it's
not mainstream that's why I love places
like jeepney that instead of a buffet
they make it a sit-down restaurant all
right here's some of the basic rules
when you eat at a Filipino house you
ready and one we don't give a [ __ ] if
you've beaten already and we don't care
if you're a fool you're about to get
more fool second roll you ready for this
mm-hmm there's no knives we don't cut
your spoon and your fork are your
utensils spoon goes on the right hand
before it goes on the left hand hold the
meat down with your fork and then pull
with your spoon and that's how you cut
you don't need knives we use those for
weapons we also have one more rule if
you don't have utensils you just wash
your hands so it goes down on the plate
and then you clasp the rice like you
like you're grabbing a teddy bear like
that they come up and then win the prize
Wiener Wiener Wiener Filipino dinner
so today what we're doing is just some
of the Filipino menu Greatest Hits yes
we'll bring them out I love it hit me
with the first dish what we have in
front of us John
you better know the name of this right
now arroz caldo yes autoscout though I
think every ethnicity has that one go to
when someone's feeling sick hungover
whatever the case may be it's a go-to oh
yeah this is that catch-all for the
people out there it's a ginger and rice
chicken soup topped with bits of fried
chickens chicken and then you get the
side condiments and talk me through this
okay I always did the lemon so grab
eleven we's it all in there get all the
juices as much features as you can that
is your vitamin C shot then you grab an
egg you can use your fork or yes no I'm
going use it use a cloth do you want to
do the garlic with your spoon or do you
want to do with your hand stove you
picked up a distance I feel like you're
gonna leading the witness because I know
your hands been this my friend is called
fatties say it but these but these I
think every Southeast Asian has a fish
sauce but no one has it like the
Filipinos is that too much now I like
that I like it okay and then I'll do the
same all right you ready I'm ready take
your spoon well actually you can mix it
all together you know chop up the eggs
[Music]
I can tell you know when you are saying
we're sick when you have your back
against the ropes this is the thing that
brings you back to life and it's very
much tastes like that you have a
superpower this will save your life you
call in sick this is this better be on
the stuff if I understand it correctly
this is like the poster child this is
the crown jewel of Filipino yeah food is
that accurate I dare anyone to say they
don't like Filipino food and I will drop
this bowl right in front of your face I
guarantee you're gonna be like what was
that
I never sugar like that what's in there
so new flavors traditionally it's it's
garlic soy and vinegar right and chicken
lot so you and a lot of oil a lot of
oily fat from the skin so the broth
doesn't look appealing when you make it
at home but when you eat it you're like
oh my god that's delicious and then you
can present it like this and you can
actually take a picture of that that's
about 400 likes hashtag chicken adobo if
we're at a restaurant people watching
this heat you can do it the proper way I
guess grab the spoon and the fork what
holds it what holds the meat down yeah
the pork they ready grab the meat with
your court all right you're not fighting
you're not fighting the meat a little
touch a little touch not like this
what are you doing time take the spoon
and then just pull the meat right on it
all right oh hold on no no leave it
leave it
we're gonna go ahead and shove some of
that stuff onto the spoon because we
want more than just chicken yeah more
than you want everything got that oh
that's a nice little portion you can put
on your ice shovel the rice onto the
spoon
mushroom yes the chicken those rice
which always do you know sponges up that
sauce this is my favorite dish I know
I'm probably gonna say that about every
dish oh I don't think I'll say it about
the next one I already know see I
already know it's just the way you
deliver that line I already know what
you're gonna do and it's not cool I put
it in my right or not to do it I know
it's fine it's your show and you're wild
so I have a feeling you knew that this
was coming this is I specifically told
you not to we always ignore those sorts
of requests sorry if anything we double
and triple down on them yeah so this is
balut
but look balut there you go can you talk
through balut for me it's almost a baby
dunk I mean every culture has that food
item that no one really wants to eat
talk about it but everyone there's
someone in the family that enjoys it but
no one else really does so you sworn
this off you had it before what I did it
was I think I was six when I did it and
I'll never do it again
it's that kind of situation yeah man we
live you know we live in a place where
we don't need to eat these so why do we
have it eggs right we have regular eggs
let's just eat that so the big part so
here's the pointy part yeah but that's
the bottom are they're gonna smack this
part right here be careful like I said
take one more time more yeah this one's
a fighter oh man no one this kid has his
backpack on alright there you go ah you
ready I'm not doing this man here okay
I'll do it you know so you gotta open
the top like this you want to keep the
sauce and I look this is you know you
said you're gonna do it I didn't do it
okay alright put some salt on there yeah
I can't but salt I don't know why you
need salt because your muffin you about
to drink the bambietta cool it so I just
keep it up no you're gonna sip it you're
gonna grab it God why do you don't grab
the egg don't get it on me Austria and
then sip it sip sip sip okay don't come
back down now this little hard thing
right there is the Nugget eat it eat
that I'm gonna throw up in your mouth
okay okay I did do it now shove the
whole bird in your mouth I kids I don't
know if I can do that you have to do it
I can't do it I can't do it I can
[ __ ] feel feathers
yeah it's fighting for its lucky I can't
do that what we're time I can't do it I
wouldn't do it it's just too I wouldn't
do it I told you not to I put it in the
writer don't do balloon and then you
thought oh so here
enjoy laughs all right sort of bringing
things home with some hallo hallo which
is our dessert dish today and then this
particular dish it's like a shaved ice
thing super sweet and a total blank
canvas and on this one in particular it
looks like we pulled no punches yeah
this one is the mecca right here down at
the bottom we got Fonda we got Jeff red
beans young coconut the shaved ice
evaporated milk is what gives it that
consistency and that's that Chaplin ube
ice cream which is purple yeah rice
krispies and that's about it
this is what you want to do you ready
take the spoon and you want to just do
this bring the stuff all up to the
surface there you go yes slow down
I'm very cement mixer yeah ready go and
it takes so long to eat it then it
starts to melt down into like this
really yummy tight milkshake hence the
reason why this turns into a straw this
is a brilliant utensil yeah right here
yeah for those that don't see it it's
just a straw spoon which is alone strong
raw your perspective from somebody who
travels all over the country somebody
who lives in LA who comes to New York
do you think that Filipino food is
primed for some sort of mainstream cross
it's it's time I always felt in my heart
that it's been time like you just saw
like you just witnessed the three things
that we did before was just amazing
and I can see that on any menu anywhere
across the United States and people will
enjoy it we can go to Nashville right
now and I swear to God there will be a
cowboy want to I get some more of that
chicken Adobe all right well there you
have it it's Filipino food 101 from jo
koy and if it comes from Jo you know
it's gospel if you want to see Amy's
going on tour it's the break the mold
tour and you get tickets jo koy calm
love yeah I did that and then you can
catch his show and glorious pranksters
on the lol Network Netflix special got
to watch it very funny
for first we feast you already know
otherwise you wouldn't be here this is
Sean Evans signing off
[Music]